hi welcome to our session on automating
the modernization of vm-based
applications to containers
my name is jason delorme and i'm joined
by my peer mike coleman
there's three areas of modernization
that you can consider when moving
applications to the cloud
the first is infrastructure
modernization and when we think about
this on the axis of complexity
and value
infrastructure modernization is by far
the easiest step
as you graduate through this scale
complexity increases with changing code
and building cloud native applications
all the way up to
process automation
moving and adopting cloud native
technologies also requires
how optimizing devops practices and
optimizing your people and processes
so really to land those first few
workloads we're going to talk to you
today about infrastructure modernization
and some of the options that you have
here
often customers go through and
application rationalization exercise in
order to determine which applications to
move to the cloud in which order
so the first category of applications
often called legacy applications and
sometimes even referred to as monolith
applications that you know all of the
functionality is into a single binary or
one complicated application and
monoliths aren't always a bad thing but
when they're vm based and potentially
they take a long time to start they load
logs they load cache they you know don't
necessarily
lend themselves to being able to be
replicated into multiple instances
we think of these
traditionally as not ready for cloud
native however they can be re-hosted
into infrastructure vms so moving from
on-prem vms into a vm in infrastructure
as a service for example
the other option is to start thinking
about maybe decomposing that monolith
and reimagining it and refactoring to
cloud native services
the second area or what we might think
of is container ready and this actually
might be
bigger than you think
the options here you can clearly re-host
these applications into an is-based
approach with vms or you could
re-platform them to something like
kubernetes and put them in a container
and have them orchestrated this is
really going to be the focus of our talk
here today
you know as you think about some of
these others
container
cloud compatible or cloud friendly or
cloud native applications that might
already be in containers those are
certainly candidates we'll dive into
number two today
so what are containers you know if
you've been
under a rock for the last um you know
five six seven years
um then you've probably never heard the
term container and ultimately they're a
method for packaging up an application
and all of its dependencies you know the
most common phrase you hear related to
containers is it works on my machine
hence it will work in the cloud it will
work on somebody else's machine and we
often get away from some of those you
know mysterious dependency issues or
configuration issues that weren't
necessarily there when you ran it on
your laptop and dev for example
other phrases that we hear often
associated with containers things like
being lightweight because it doesn't
take the entire operating system it's
just your application and all the
dependencies it becomes more portable
it's using a standardized format that
can be used it helps increase
productivity and ultimately helps drive
security as well
so why do we do this why do we build
containers
if you think of a traditional vm-based
application often choices were made to
put an application per vm inside of a
customer's infrastructure because of
that bleeding over of dependencies maybe
one application leverages a shared
library that can get overwritten and
that can create havoc for the
other application we ultimately optimize
those applications for the minimum vm
constraints for the operating system
certain amount of memory certain amount
of cpu and disk
not based on the applications
requirements itself so we often see
underutilized hardware being leveraged
and also a complicated rollout process
for every single vm because every single
app has its own vm if we can move to a
place where applications can coexist and
not step on each other and not conflict
with each other in a single vm we can
get to a place where we're optimizing
the infrastructure optimizing even the
licensing costs since often the
operating system is licensed at the vm
and not at the container if i can get
two applications into a single vm i've
halved my licensing costs for that or i
can get to high availability easier with
the same licensing costs because i can
have two instances of this application
running
each vm now has two instances here
so
i mentioned the the container-based
approach you can use containers for
windows or linux machines now windows is
a little bit more recent when it comes
to adopting containerized strategies
for that reason there are a few
different behaviors versus linux which
it was built from the beginning to
support containers
there are a handful of things you need
to think about when moving to a
containerized environment in an
orchestrator like kubernetes
specifically
some of those
windows containers don't support
privileged pods that means those things
like virus scanning software really live
at the vm level they don't live inside
the container itself
those types of services need to be
examined
anything that has low level network
dependencies where it's dependent on
something below layer seven the
networking stack for example you don't
necessarily want to to to depend on the
ip address of another machine or joining
a cluster where there's a heartbeat in
between and they need to know the static
ip address can be a little bit problem
problematic when you're when you think
about ips and we can talk about ways of
addressing that you know if there's
low-level gpu or tpu support this isn't
available in a windows container yet
cloud native features like istio to
create a service mesh in order to uh
help us with uh with traffic management
and service discovery this isn't
supported in windows containers just yet
uh nor is being able to use uh something
like cloud run or k-native the open
source version where you could steal the
xero in a server-less environment not
quite ready for windows containers
so let's talk about what is ready and
what are the ideal container candidates
so first off i would look at your web
applications your web and logic tiers
you know things that maybe they're
written in python php java.net
for example
those things hosted in iis those are
great candidates potentially to run
inside of a container in a container
orchestrated environment like kubernetes
another area to look at is batch jobs or
console applications that maybe run
spiky workloads um things that run maybe
uh you know every day at six pm or
things that run and listen to cues they
don't have any kind of kind of gui to
them um they're they're an ideal
candidate even windows services those
are applications that are registered
with the windows operating system to
begin at startup for example they may
even log to the windows application
event log all these things can be
containerized and run in a container
orchestrator
now let me jump to the lower right hand
side of this and talk about
those container workloads that are
potentially unsuitable and i'm going to
start right away i mentioned gui the
graphical user interface anything that
has a gui is not going to be a good
candidate for a container you can't run
a remote desktop protocol session for
example into a container so you know
virtualized desktop infrastructure vdi
for example is not a fit for containers
if the application you're using
um is primarily centered around user
interaction through a win32 console for
example that is not something that's
going to run inside of a container
now there's a gray area of things that
you may want to investigate further and
use a fit assessment tool for example to
determine whether it's appropriate for
running in a container things on the
linux side where there's a gpu or tpu
dependency
areas where the container requires
elevated privileges
another big category here is commercial
office of off-the-shelf software or cots
now most isvs have come out with newer
versions of their applications that are
containerized already so it's often a
good fit to think about maybe a version
upgrade that will will take you to their
container-based approach however there
are a lot of applications where maybe
the vendor is no longer in business or
maybe it's critical to the business but
you know nobody really knows what the
application was written in you just have
the binaries they don't have access to
the source code they could be a fit
however we should run an assessment tool
here in order to determine whether or
not it will work well in a containerized
environment and with that i'd like to
introduce my peer mike coleman who can
talk to you about a solution that we
have at google to help you with this
mike
thanks jason i want to talk to you today
about a tool called migrate for anthos
and gke we built this tool to help
automate the migration of virtual
machine based workloads from
environments like amazon
aws
vmware azure and even google cloud
compute engine this tool automatically
inspect those container those virtual
machines excuse me and convert them to
containers where then you can start
taking advantage of some of the benefits
that jason mentioned previously things
like
improved resource utilization
unified logging and monitoring and then
potentially day two operations
so it's one thing to talk about a tool
it's another thing to actually show it
so i want to do a quick demo where i'm
going to take you through a payment
service based uh virtual machine
migration so i have an online boutique
an online shopping and a bunch of the
services are already running in
containers so think of the front-end the
shopping cart some of those services
they call back to a payment service
that's running in a virtual machine on
google cloud we're going to migrate that
vm into a container and integrate it
with the rest of the application we'll
start with the fit assessment as jason
mentioned it's critical to understand
how well your vm based workload can run
in a container from there we're going to
create a migration plan we'll make a few
tweaks to that we'll run the migration
we'll get a set of deployment artifacts
we'll deploy those and then finally
we'll edit the uh service discovery so
that it's not looking for the virtual
machine but rather the payment service
running as a kubernetes
service this is the vm that we're going
to migrate today into a container
running on kubernetes
so let's go ahead i'm going to go up
here and close this down because we
don't need it anymore and let's take a
look at this application actually
running so if i come over here and i
click on one of the products the antique
camera
i click add to cart
and then i click place order
everything's working as expected that
order was processed using the payment
service on the virtual machine so the
first thing we need to do to get this
all working though is to stop the
payment service vm a virtual machine
can't be migrated until it's stopped
with the vm stopped let's go ahead and
clear the screen and close out of cloud
shell now let's take a look at the
migration fit assessment i've created a
report by running an agent on the
virtual machine and it's stored here in
this json file i can upload this into
cloud console and it's going to give me
an indication that my application is a
good fit for migration if i want to
drill down i can click on the name and
get a list of all the different things
that were inspected we know that we're
good to go here so why don't we go ahead
and close out of this and actually start
the migration
i'm going to go over here and i'm going
to click on migrations and i'm going to
click create migration
i'm going to give my migration a name
i'm going to call it online boutique
migration we'll choose our source
the instance name was payment service vm
and we're going to just do the image so
let's create the migration
in the interest of time i've sped this
up so we can move on to our next step
which is to review and edit the
migration plan so the migration plan
comes up and the first thing i want to
do is add an annotation until migrate
for gke to create an image that can run
on an autopilot cluster i also want to
go and adjust the image name and the
kubernetes service name and deployment
name to payment service instead of
payment service vm since we're not
running in a vm any longer
so this takes a few minutes i've sped
the video up i'll rejoin you when it's
finished
with the process completed let's take a
look at the artifacts that were created
so i've come down here under next steps
i click options and review artifacts and
that will bring up a list of what was
created for us the first thing you'll
see are a couple of docker images one
that we'll actually deploy and that one
we can use for day two operations we
also get a docker file and a kubernetes
deployment spec so if i open up cloud
shell you'll see that i've already
downloaded these files so i'll do an ls
here you can see all the files now this
kubernetes deployment spec.yaml is going
to create a new kubernetes deployment
and it's going to create a new
kubernetes service for our migrated
workload so let's go ahead and do that
let's make sure everything started we'll
take a look at the service and there it
is running and let's take a look at the
pod and it's running as well so what
we're going to do now is check on our
application now actually i expect this
to fail so let's come in here let's
click on the typewriter and let's go
ahead and add that to our car
and check out so it's in our car place
order now what happened is it's trying
to reach the payment service on the dns
name of the vm so what we need to do is
actually modify the deployment spec for
our application and we need to change it
from looking at the internal dns name of
the vm to the kubernetes service name so
that's payment service so we'll chop off
the dns name here and just leave payment
service we'll save that out
and then we can go back in and rerun
that deployment yaml and that's going to
reprovision our services so let's go
ahead and do that we'll do a kube ctl
apply and apply that updated boutique
deployment.yaml
it'll reconfigure the services
so let's go ahead and clear the screen
here let's look at the pods it looks
like the checkout service has been
reconfigured and is running so if i come
in here and i
click on the typewriter and i add it to
cart and i place order everything is
working as expected we've successfully
migrated our payment service from a
virtual machine into a container running
on a gke autopilot cluster using migrate
for gke
so that's the demo and demos are great
they give you a feel for the product you
can see some of the things in action but
it's important also to look at how the
tools used in the real world so i want
to start by discussing a customer
example this is the telegraph their
content management content publication
service over in the uk and they had a
legacy content management system that
they were running that was super
important to their business but it was a
little difficult for them to manually
migrate it into containers so they used
migrate for anthos to do that work for
them
vastly simplified the process and
they're already realizing savings not
just on the infrastructure as jason
mentioned before with the bin packing
and whatnot but also in the day-to-day
operation
of that cms
so that's one customer that's one
example now what about yourself now if
you're gonna look at migrating there's
some things i want you to consider
these are six items they're not
insurmountable by any stretch of the
imagination that really presented here
just as a
things for you to be aware of and the
first we saw in the demo
we were using vm based dns hostname
discovery right so we had the dns name
of that payment service we converted
that to a kubernetes service so we let
kubernetes take care of that sewers
discovery using its own internal dns
structure
along those same lines if you have host
files that you've customized and you've
got host file host names you can use
host aliases in the pod spec to take
care of that so that's another simple
migration again looking at the pod yaml
a couple other things we could take care
of are file shares so file shares are
great you can use them we just don't
automatically migrate them for you
you're going to need to define nfs
persistent volumes inside of the pod
spec to take care of those
and the same with environment variables
you may be using an environment variable
for the uri for your database for
instance um you can actually define that
same environment variable in the pod
spec and then you don't need to change
any other applications because you're
getting the same information you're
expecting so define the environment
variable uh in the pod yaml and that'll
take care of that
now i want to say something
and i might say kind of forcefully but
because i really believe it
just because you're migrating something
to a container doesn't mean that you
don't have to understand how it works
and how it runs a matter of fact if you
want to have a successful migration it's
critical that you understand what you
have and how it works
when you go in and you look at a
migration you should be looking at the
services and the agents that are running
in that vm and make a conscious decision
on whether or not you need them in your
container for instance uh you may have
an agent running that's doing logging
and monitoring um and we'll talk about
that a little bit in the next bullet
point but you probably want to disable
that
you also want to make sure you're
running at the right run level so go
through audit those services disable the
ones you don't need
that will help minimize container image
size and improve performance and it'll
reduce complexity so this is a really
important one that i want you to go
through the other thing that it's not
specifically called out here along the
same vein file system structure right
are there directories um and files that
you don't need in the resulting image
right you can you can
tell migrate for anthos and migrate for
gke to not include certain directories
certain files again smaller image size
better performance
and then finally i alluded
alluded to it
application logging
we integrate migrate for anthoc and
migrate for gke with the migrate the
cloud google cloud metrics logging and
monitoring services so you don't
actually need to have those agents you
don't need to do that work in the
container we'll just pick that stuff up
for you and you can monitor it in cloud
console
right there within google cloud
so that's what we have for you today i
really want to thank you for tuning in
on behalf of myself and jason uh why
don't you go out have a great rest of
your day and and look at migrating some
of those vm workloads
you